whenever an actor decides to use the
method approach to a role it usually
ends up making headlines the process of
an actor really getting their head
inside a character has made for some
jaw-dropping performances and some
shocking behind-the-scenes tales here
are just a few times method actors have
taken things too far for a part Adrien
Brody in 2002 Adrien Brody scored the
role of a lifetime when director Roman
Polanski picked him to star as Polish
Jewish musician and composer
Vladislav Spillman in The Pianist the
actor immediately buried himself in
Spillman's World War two memoirs in
order to better understand the role
after being forced into the warsaw
ghetto and separated from his family
Spillman eluded Nazi forces and survived
the Holocaust by hiding in the ruins of
Warsaw to prepare for the parts the
six-foot-one Brody spent six weeks on an
intense diet to get down to a mere 130
pounds before filming began for the
better part of a year
Brody essentially dropped out of modern
society he moved to Europe sold his car
and disconnected his cell phone because
the character loses so much I wanted to
kind of have a glimpse of what that loss
would feel like after filming wrapped it
took over half a year for Brody to
recover he later admitted there were
times when I was concerned that I might
not be able to get out of it same
because they didn't realize how far it
had taken me in the end his dedication
to the role paid off in a big way not
only did the pianist earn widespread
acclaim and accolades but Brody won the
Academy Award for Best Actor making him
the youngest winner ever in that
category Jim Carrey in 1999 Jim Carrey
took a deep dive in the method acting
when he played comedian Andy Kaufman in
man on the moon while a handful of
stories from the set made it into the
news over the years a 20-17 Netflix
documentary revealed many more
jaw-dropping moments from the film's
production in Jim and Andy the great
beyond it becomes clear that Kerry's
dedication to the role went way beyond
spitting in the face of professional
wrestler Jerry Lawler during the shoot
Harry didn't just play Kaufman he
channeled to the point where he would
refer to Jim Carrey as a completely
different person
Jim had trouble later on
kind of loop that he got angry as Andy
Kerry also had emotional reunions with
members of Kaufman's family including an
hour-long conversation with his daughter
who never got a chance to meet her
father before he passed away from lung
cancer in 1984 so that day she came into
Andy's trailer and talked to her father
as Kaufman's vulgar alter ego Tony
Clifton Carrey went on drunken tirades
crashed a convertible and stormed into
Steven Spielberg's office to chat with
him about jaws even though Carrie won
praise for his performance the role
clearly took a toll on him and he later
claimed he could barely remember who he
was after filming Nicolas Cage he might
be better known today for his goofy
action movies and eccentric spending
habits but Nicolas Cage is also
dedicated to method acting his approach
to acting as yielded mixed results over
the years he earned acclaim for films
like adaptation and leaving Las Vegas
and derision for movies like the
Wickerman
one of his best method roles dates back
to the early days of his acting career
when he was cast in the 1984 war drama
birdie in the film cage plays a
disfigured Vietnam veteran who visits a
friend from the war in a psychiatric
hospital to prepare for the part the vim
nineteen-year-old page had his wisdom
teeth extracted without anesthesia he
also spent weeks with his face bandaged
day and night so he could experience the
physical pain and discomfort his
character was going through his
impressive dedication to the part shows
and cages work in birdy remains one of
his best early performances Christian
Bale while method acting began as a way
to harness personal experiences and
emotions as a way to play a part more
convincingly in recent years it's become
almost synonymous with drastic physical
transformations in one prominent example
Christian Bale made headlines and
jeopardized his health when he lost a
job dropping 63 pounds to play the
insomnia plagued Trevor Reznik in 2004's
The Machinist
four weeks before filming began Bale
survived on just an apple and a can of
tuna fish a day according to his
machinist co-star Michael Ironside the
drastic diet wasn't even necessary
the screenwriter for the movie had put
some example weights into the script
based on his own height when the much
taller Bale saw the figures he decided
to go for those weights instead of
something more realistic for his bigger
frame after filming wrapped failed
bulked up again gaining 109 pounds in
just six months for his next role in
Batman Begins
he's gone on to use drastic weight
changes in preparation for other parts
too
more recently Bale shaved his head and
packed on the pounds to play former US
Vice President Dick Cheney and the 2018
biopic backseat Martin Sheen after
director Francis Ford Coppola fired
Harvey Keitel from 1979 s Apocalypse Now
two weeks into production victim art and
Sheen to take Keitel's place as Captain
Benjamin L Willard Sheen's approach was
to use experiences from his own life to
bring himself closer to his character
Sheen certainly brought his own demons
with him to the set his personal
struggle with alcoholism played a key
role in the film's famous opening scene
the actor was completely drunk that day
and Coppola captured the unscripted
mirror smashing weeping and blood
smearing the following when production
moved to the jungle Sheehan told his
friends that he wasn't sure he'd make it
out of the shoot alive and he almost
didn't sheen actually suffered a heart
attack and crawled for a quarter mile to
a road where he was found and airlifted
to a hospital he was back on the set
just six weeks later in this case at
least it wasn't just one actor who was
uncontrollable on set from the tropical
diseases that ravaged the crew to actual
cadavers showing up on the set the
entire shoot was chaotic if anything it
would have been weird if Martin Sheen
hadn't acted weird Matt Damon he may be
famous today for movies like Good Will
Hunting and the Jason Bourne franchise
but in the early 1990s Matt Damon was
just another unknown actor all that
changed when he was cast in the 1996 war
drama courage under fire to prepare for
the role of an ex medic with a drug
addiction
Damon dropped down to a mere 139 pounds
by running 13 miles a day and subsisting
on the diet made almost entirely of
chicken breast the drastic weight loss
took an enormous toll on his body after
filming wraps he had to take a special
medication for a year and a half just to
repair the damage done to his adrenal
gland Daniel day-lewis for much of his
career three-time Oscar winner Daniel
Day Lewis has been notorious for his
intense approach to method acting the
actors behavior on and off the set is
the stuff of legend in preparation for
his role as John Proctor in the crucible
day-lewis went back to basics literally
he lived for months on the set of a 17th
century village with no electricity or
running water built his characters home
by hand with only tools from that era
and even gave up his beloved motorcycle
in favor of a horse Ashton Kutcher after
Apple CEO Steve Jobs passed away in 2011
the race was on in Hollywood to develop
a feature film based on the moguls
remarkable
life for the 2013 independent film jobs
director Joshua Michael Stern picked
Ashton Kutcher to portray the complex
computer pioneer and the actor spent
three months preparing for the role
watching hundreds of hours of archival
footage to understand jobs accent
posture and facial expressions he didn't
stop there
Kutcher also tried adopting a fruit only
diet similar to the one that Jobs
adopted as part of an alternative
medicine regimen to treat his cancer for
Kutcher the drastic diet caused its own
health issues two days before filming
began he ended up in the hospital with
pancreas problems Kutcher explained I
was like doubled over in pain my
pancreas levels were completely out of
whack it was really terrifying
in the end Kutcher's dedication paid off
while Jobs received mixed reviews and
was criticized for its historical
inaccuracies Kutcher's performance
earned praise what are you gonna do fire
me
no I already fired you why are you still
here
[Music]